good evening and welcome to this full
council meeting today thursday the 16th
of december 2021
my name is councillor mark hurd and i'm
chairman of malden district council
set up for this meeting has been
designed to mitigate for covid therefore
in the interests of membranes officer
safety all present should work to the
protocols agreed at council on the 2nd
of december
2021 and remain seated
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to agenda papers
because the business from the 4th of
november was unfinished this has been
added to tonight's agenda so please keep
your contributions clear and concise
as you know we are streaming this
meeting live as well as recording
but the youtube live stream sound
recording is dependent on the
uh
correct use of microphones
therefore please remember to turn on
your microphone when invited to speak
and turn it off when finished please
note that by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
i'd also like to draw your attention to
the different levels within the chamber
the fire exit is the door behind this
top table
please avoid approaching the top table
in front of the cameras
as there are live feeds that are
hazardous and affect our streaming
so members following detailed
discussions um today about uh this
meeting uh i've also canvassed a number
of
members on this uh i can say that we
have had clarification from the director
of public health that we're working to
all the mitigations
that we can to be within public guidance
he's highlighted that masks should now
be considered compulsory when you are
not speaking
on this basis i have confirmed that the
meeting will go ahead um as planned
so agenda item number two
yeah clarification
counselor yeah
thank you chairman and i i appreciate uh
you letting me ask a question at this
early stage if you've consulted with the
director of uh public health dr gogerty
was he aware that the covid safe number
for this chamber was 17
whereas there are now 30 plus med people
in this chamber and i didn't have that
conversation with him i'm only going on
what the emadison sent to me
councillor councillor morris
thank you uh councillor
can i just ask what is the actual
information you've been given because i
would like to view it myself please i've
just given you the information that i've
had i've read it out what so you've had
a report i understand i've had an email
and i've read that out what i want
to want to move on now
i'd like to move to agenda item two
apologies for absence
tara do i have any apologies please
apologize
thank you very much
we now move on to agenda item 3
declarations of interest this is to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs six to eight inclusive in the
code of conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
council again
yeah thank you chair uh declare an
opportunity interest in agenda iron 17
i've had email correspondence from a
resident within that area for which i
have acknowledged the email thank you
thank you very much councillor durham
uh thank you very much uh chairman i
have non-security interests as being a
member of
essex county council and in relation to
item 17 on the agenda
uh i will not be voting because the land
is under the ownership of essex county
council although there is no pecuniary
element
and i also wish to declare an interest
as
a governor of the essex partnership nhs
trust thank you
thank you very much councillor stamp
um yes thank you chairman i'm also a
member of essex county council um i've
got non-pecuniary interest in agenda
item 17 but i don't see that i need to
not vote
um because it's not the cuner even
though i'm a member of essex county
council thank you thank you very much
councillor mays
uh yeah non-pecuniary um interest in
item 13 as i live in the parish and item
14 as i am the
uh sep representative thank you that's
noted thank you councillor chenna
uh thank you chairman i'll just declare
non-pecuniary in 17 similar to council
lag and i've read some correspondence in
but i have done ever since i think um
this uh sort of site or you know
proposed site from
uh chance that has come up so i just
declare in time that you know that's the
only thing i'm aware with these people
so i'm just declaring i've received
something as well thank you very much
and councillor darren again yeah and
just to clarify on item 17 uh the reason
i won't be voting is because in my
capacity uh at essex county council i
was involved in meetings regarding this
project
council morris
thank you uh i need to make this
declaration um
i feel like i've been uh this is my
little preamble um i feel like i've been
let down badly by this council
uh their council tax uh is being given
to former employees to cover up crimes
um that uh what is your declaration
please i'm getting around to it if you
don't interrupt me i'll i'll finish it
we're on declaration and i'm doing the
declaration i'm allowed to preamble
please get to the point i will get to
the point when i get to the point
up until that time i'm making the
declaration you're not trying to stop me
making the declaration now mark are you
i want you to make a declaration and i'm
going to make a declaration please don't
interrupt let's hear it so um i've been
badly let down by this council and uh
the money that uh they're asking from me
for council tax i don't want giving to
ex-employees to cover up crimes by
current serving officers do i miss the
homes
i also have been badly failed by essex
police i've recently had um the police
been called and threatened sorry
councilman this is not a declaration
this is a declaration i'm telling you
why i'm making the declaration
or not this is a declaration i'm telling
you why i'm making the declaration you
don't get you don't get this is a
declaration of interest right four
twenty
as everyone knows i've had my life
threatened i've had the police have had
calls saying they're going to shoot me
in the head and i've even had i've even
been
there
oh so now you're refusing my declaration
just like you refused the point of order
you're a declaration then let me get to
it
let me get to it you haven't heard
other people have just commented and you
haven't spoke about that have you now
are you going to let me finish council i
heard
i will give you one more chance to give
your declaration i don't want any
preamble i want the declaration sorry i
give my declaration it's my declaration
not yours to demand
so would you like my
declaration members i move that
counselor morris no longer be heard well
that's not going to work with it
sorry guys i'm still speaking
are you going to accept my declaration
thank you can i take that to the vote
please
show of hands
that is carried you are no longer heard
no i am heard i'm a democratically
elected member and i will be held morris
if you continue to talk you have failed
i will accept my declaration my
declaration not the declaration you
demand
i simply wanted to put my declaration
across referring to rule 10 which is
disorderly conduct you cannot
be disorderly either if you are giving a
declaration i shall move that you leave
the meeting i will not be leaving the
meeting i am democratically elected and
i'm supposed to be here i'm giving you
one last chance to make the declaration
your your threats do not impress me
right in that case i i hereby
hear
that counselor morris leave the meeting
i won't be moving anywhere guys you know
this one a show of hands please
thank you recorded vote please i will
now
i will now adjourn this meeting in order
that council morris can leave i won't be
i won't be moving guys you know that
i won't be moving so tara can you tell
me when the live feed is off please
members
councillor morris has been requested
councillor morris has been requested to
obey the resolution of council
to leave the chamber
because of disorderly conduct
he does not
the meeting will be closed
and councillor morris will have present
will have prevented this council from
transacting business
councilor morris do you refuse to leave
send me on fresh service
i'm now going to close this meeting uh
because of councillor morris's refusal
to obey a resolution of counsel
and his conduct has deliberately
prevented the transaction of business
additionally within the constitution
the directors have power to make
decisions with their emergency powers
and they will exercise them when
necessary
i will now close this meeting at 2017.